right a previous project that they were
a part of i mean it's hard
to not guess yours when you're
dominating the world with euphoria so
i i mean if i don't get that correct i
probably live
in a rock like patrick from spongebob we
did
big time adolescence together yes which
also was the next question which was the
first time we met
syracuse new york big time adolescence
i mean me and pete were kind of super
disliked by
the globe at that point and like you
were really nice to both of us
the first day i showed up to set you and
pete were dancing on top of the trailers
oh my god yes yes i remember that
walking and you guys are literally like
tattooing each other i'm like okay this
is like the coolest
that i've ever been on he gave me the
worst tattoo i got seriously
tattooed loco on me but it looks like it
says coco is that a latte
oh my goodness is that a lot of oh
no but that's the funniest guess of a
tattoo i've ever had
that's really funny and it should be a
latte because i'm obsessed with